ROBERT SAXBY: So, we're going
to have a little deep dive
into machine learning today.
I thought we'd take
the opportunity
to build some models and
stuff like that, and no.
We're going to have a look at
useful applications in machine
learning.
So we're going to start
with some use cases.
So I couldn't resist.
I know that you had an astronaut
here today and I thought,
I had to take a photo
that you should all
know from the Kuiper Belt.
So the little blue dot
there, that's us.
In 1990, this was Voyager
turning back a six billion--
yeah, six billion kilometers
from Earth and actually
looking and saying bye.
And that's all that was left
of us, this little blue dot.
So we're going to zoom in a bit,
because my use case is actually
done here on Earth.
This is my favorite
view of the Earth.
Every time I get on in plane
and I fly across the Atlantic,
I start playing around
with that screen
once I've watched all
20 films I didn't see.
And then I start looking at
where the plane's flying.
And then I'm twiddling
the globe around.
And I always like to
get this backward face
of the globe, where you
can't see any land on it.
I think it's a really nice
way of looking at the planet.
And it gives you a
kind of perspective.
It really kind of messes
with your head a little bit.
You have to think, is it really?
So this use case I'm
going to tell us about--
actually, whenever
we tell this use case
at Google for a
conference, for example,
we always mention this island.
And I didn't know
where it was so I
thought I'd take the effort
and find out where it was.
And it happened to be slap
bang in the middle of that view
that I like to look at so much.
And I don't know if you
can see this here properly.
So the island is
called Kiribati.
And this island
has villages on it.
This is nothing to with
machine learning yet.
This it just really interesting.
So this island has villages on
it of London, Paris, Poland,
and Banana.
So like, if you ever look
into anything, you can--
so, what is the use case?
The use case is global fishing.
Maybe some of you've
heard about it.
It's a really cool use case.
And normally we
show this picture.
So we show this picture of
all these boat moving around,
and Africa and Madagascar.
So I thought Kiribati
was there, but it's not.
It's on the other side.
So that was my little
adventure into coming up
to this use case.
So what's going on here?
Basically, whenever
a fishing boat
passes through a
certain zone, they
want to know if they're actually
allowed to be fishing there.
And whenever they catch someone
that's illegally fishing,
they say, oh, we were
just passing through.
Yeah, that's a bit of a problem.
OK, if their nets were down
in the water, but you know,
you've got some time
to get the nets out.
The say, oh, we were
just passing through.
So the machine learning
application that they looked at
was actually to take
this data, and we're
talking about 40
billion rows of events,
and we've got 200,000 ships
broadcasting AIS all the time.
That's the little
positioning stuff for boats.
And what they did
was actually work out
how these boats are
traversing the water,
and what patterns correspond
to fishing patterns.
And they applied this, and
so they could actually now
actually start finding
well, fishing companies
that were illegally fishing.
And one of the first ever
successful prosecutions
was in the waters of Kiribati.
And they fine that they actually
issued was $2.2 million,
which was 1% of the
country's global GDP.
This is something you can
do with machine learning.
I'm guessing most people here
are interested in fishing
waters and stuff like that.
So this is like,
really take note
and you can start
applying this as well.
I'm going to take a few use
cases today from retail.
The reason I'm
going to do retail
is because I think
it's quite broad
and everyone has some
association with retail.
Either we're working with
retail or we're involved
in buying for ourselves.
So we've got a
good understanding.
So Ocado is a
British supermarket.
They are online.
They're online only.
It's got a ton of
active customers.
Well five tons of
them, to be precise.
And basically what
they want to do,
they want to process
all the messages that
are coming at them.
So they've got all
these messages coming in
on email and social media
and things like that.
And if one of their customers
is unhappy about something--
maybe the delivery didn't
turn up on time, or the food
was damaged, or whatever-- they
want to capture that message
and act.
So they're-- you know,
customer satisfaction is really
important to them.
So they have to process
all these messages.
This message here is
like someone, I'm happy.
You know, my children
love the website.
It's so easy, and blah, blah.
That's great.
We'll write back to
that, but maybe later.
The thing that we
need to deal with now
is maybe another message
that's coming at us,
which is, where's my food?
So it's a way that
they can actually
take text, unstructured
text, and basically
process that, apply NLP, so
Natural Language Processing.
We offer an API for this.
And they can actually
then find out
what the sentiment of the
text is, extract the entities,
and they can then
go and use this
to actually help provide a
better customer satisfaction.
This, and I'm not going to
read them all out because it's
going to take a long time.
But these are some of
the areas within retail
where you might want to
look at machine learning.
And there's actually
quite a lot.
I mean, it ranges from
everything from supply chain
to pricing to customer insights.
So we've got this whole range,
so it's not just in one area.
It might be that you're
looking for anomalies.
It might be you're trying
to forecast a trend,
or you're trying to predict.
You're trying to
make recommendations.
So that all these
kind of applications
that you can use
machine learning for
to actually improve your
business, whether that's inside
to actually become
more economic,
or outside to improve
your relationships
with your customers, or
generate more revenue, all
those important things.
This is just a number.
It's done by a research company.
But I want this number.
It's just to basically think.
This is not the only
important number out there.
But nine in 10
people in this survey
said, if the company was able
to predict my intent better
and suggest more
intuitive products,
I would use them
above everyone else.
Now I know there are tons
of research firms coming up
with tons of
statistics like this,
but I just want to think
about it for a moment.
I just want to ask you to think
about, OK if this is happening,
if customers are starting to
expect something more from us,
can we afford not to do this?
I would say that
the answer is no.
Maybe-- I mean, I'm sure
there's a lot of discussion
to be had around that.
But if I look at my own
life, my personal life,
I see more and
more how I interact
with machine learning and AI.
Or the result, the
product of that,
whether it's, for example,
when I connect to Spotify
and I actually want to
find some new music,
or when it's, as Bill
showed us earlier,
I'm trying to work on
a document like now,
and I can just go and
find the document.
It's becoming more and
more something I use.
And it's becoming more
and more intuitive.
And I think our
customers, they really
appreciate advice which
actually seems-- this is not
something that is obstructive.
This is something that is
just actually improving
my engagement with you.
So I think that companies are
already acting in this space.
Companies are actively
thinking about this space.
They have a great
chance of actually going
forward and being
more successful
with their customers.
But what this means is that
there's a lot of work that
needs to be done
behind the scenes
to actually get that
information out so
we can start doing these things.
Recommendation engines don't
just pop up out of the ground,
you know?
You have to think about, what
data am I going to use for it?
How am I going to
collect that data?
How am I going to process it?
Which model should I choose?
And when you've done all of
those things and you think,
well great, I have this
fantastic model now.
It's able to predict
stuff for me,
and my customers really like it.
That was today.
Tomorrow, there's more
insight, there's more data.
Things are changing.
You need to go and
retrain that model,
and see if your new
model is actually
more predictive and more useful
than what you had before.
If you're not doing
that, then you're static.
These things don't just
learn by themselves.
You need to go and actually feed
them new data and retrain them.
So this is a very simple naive
look at a neural network.
Neural networks are immensely
popular at the moment
for all sorts of
things, including
things like recommendations.
There are more classical
regression models
and [INAUDIBLE].
There are more classical
things that you
could use to do
a recommendation,
like collaborative
filtering for example.
But people are starting to use--
they're looking at the
capacity of neural networks,
because neural networks have
something that's really quite
unique to them, I would say.
And that's the ability
to generalize very well.
If you can't generalize,
what does that mean?
It means for example, if I
was creating a model which
is taking advantage of a
whole load of features,
and then trying to
get a good regression,
and let's say I'm overfitting
because I'm just plugging
all that stuff in there.
And I think OK, this
is working well.
But then I go and apply
that to a new set of people,
where they're in
the same domain,
but let's say, on
the edge of it.
And things are changing.
My model, if it's
too specific, it
might not really recognize their
behavior or what's going on.
Deep neural networks
help with that.
They're very good
at generalizing.
So for recommendations,
there's actually a couple ways
that you can take like
good parts of regression,
with a more, let's say,
a more classical set up.
And then go for a deeper neural
network in the same model
to actually get
a model which has
both aspects of memorization,
so learning the things, very
important, they've seen before.
But at the same time, flexible
enough to actually be useful
and not just come with the
same answer because it's this.
So what's changed in
the last few years?
Why is this all happening now?
Well, machine learning has
been around for a long time.
And a lot of the models that
you see, especially used
in competitions up
until a few years ago,
and still when people
are running this
by themselves in
their own machines,
are kind limited by the amount
of processing power you had.
If you think about a
good model, a good model
implies that it's
probably going to have
to do quite a lot of work.
And then on top of that,
we've got a lot of data.
Now if we mash those
two things together,
we need a lot of those
things on the right
to start processing it.
These things on the
right here are our TPUs.
And you don't have to use TPUs.
You could use GPUs
or anything else.
But TPUs are actually
very useful for us.
We brought our
second generation.
This is worth standing
still, because I
think this is one
that differentiates us
with Google Cloud in the
space of machine learning.
So these things are 180
teraflops per circuit.
They're A6, so they're
designed specifically
for a certain task.
In this case
actually calculating
floating point operations.
180 tera, what does that mean?
It means, if we
put them in a pod,
and I'll show you a
photo that in a moment--
sorry, Shelby,
and she knows why.
Well, Shelby said to
let you all in the joke.
When I showed her
this photo, she said,
it looks like something
from the 1970s.
I'm a kind of 1970s guy.
But I like the '70s.
I like a lot of
stuff in the '70s,
so this really appeals to me.
These are all pods of
actually of those TPUs.
Each pod is 11
and 1/2 petaflops.
What do those numbers
mean in real terms?
What do they mean
for anyone else?
They mean, we were
translating-- for example,
we were taking our
models like Translate
and retraining that
in a couple of days.
And now we can do it
in a couple of hours.
So if you think about these use
cases that maybe were involving
lots of data and
lots of complexity,
now we have the ability to
actually go and retrain them
in relatively short
amount of time,
and to get a new model out
there which could potentially
impact our conversation
with our users.
So the message I want
to take from this
is that machine learning is
a really good fit with cloud.
Cloud offers you this,
it will provide you
this infrastructure to
go and actually take
advantage of that.
So how do we do that?
Well, we do it in two ways.
So on the one hand,
on the right hand side
here, we have our managed APIs.
This is a little bit about the
democratization of the machine
learning.
So what we're trying to
do in the machine space
is get more people involved.
I just explained in my last
talk that I have two children,
and whilst I'm not sure if
my children are going to grow
up and become data scientists--
I think one wants to be a
firefighter and the other one,
we're going to find out.
But I know when they grow up and
they participate in the world,
machine learning is
going to be there.
It's already here now.
We're on the cusp and things
are just accelerating.
I want my kids to know
what machine learning is,
what it's about, and
more importantly,
what people are using it for.
I don't want it to be
something that they
don't have that
connection with the world,
that the world just
kind of passes them by.
In our effort to democratize
artificial intelligence
and machine learning,
what we're trying to do
is provide a space for
people to interact with.
On the right hand side,
we're taking models
that we've actually trained
to solve, let's say,
common problems--
OCR, taking a translation,
going from speech to text.
We're opening them
up on open APIs
that developers can use
in their applications,
making single rest calls
to actually get a result.
So you saw the video
demo earlier, you know,
those kind of things.
So that's one way of opening
up at least the usage
and getting more
people interacting
with the capabilities.
On the left hand side, we have
TensorFlow and Cloud Machine
Learning.
I would say the big
differentiator between Google
Cloud and other
clouds, and I think
that other clouds are
actually following us,
so we definitely have
the lead in this space.
And it was the reason why
I joined Google as well.
I'm a big data fan.
And if you look at the big
data technology, a lot of it,
there's a relationship
with Google--
either they published
white papers,
or, in the most recent
years, open sourcing a ton
of frameworks.
So why is this important?
TensorFlow is an open sourced
project for machine learning.
It has something like
50,000 stars on GitHub.
So you saw Linux has 20,000.
Imagine how many people are
involved with this then?
We know everyone knows Linux.
People have an
affiliation with Linux.
So 50,000, that's 1 and 1/2
times more, are actually
they're using--
I should say 2 and 1/2
times-- but they're there,
using it, experimenting with it.
So first of all, there's
a lot of collaboration.
That innovation that we spoke
about earlier, about actually
having people
contribute to the space
and seeing what's going
on and moving the needle,
is the same thing what's
happening in machine learning.
Having it open source means we
can all collaborate and work
together.
And we have a managed service.
So we do that for our big
data frameworks as well.
But we have managed service
that you can take your model,
come and run at us.
It kind of puts the kind of,
let's say responsibility,
square on our shoulders
to do a couple of things--
make sure that we're
giving you the best price,
providing the best security,
make sure we're providing
the best performance.
And if not, you've
written it in open source,
so you can go and run
it somewhere else.
So you know your
investment's in good hands.
Also, if a lot of people
are working on this project,
it means there are a lot of
developers and data scientists
and analysts out there
in the market that
are working with it.
So when you're looking
to recruit more people
to actually accelerate
your effort in that space,
there are people
in the market that
understand this technology.
You don't have to go and
just start from scratch
and train them in something new.
So open source is
a really big part
of machine learning as well.
If you're not using
an open source
framework for your machine
learning, shame on you.
You really should
start considering it,
because it really will
put you in a better
position for the future.
This is a quick architecture.
And we don't have to go
for all the details here,
but what I basically say,
this is the architecture
of the Video API.
The most difficult part
of this, the part that
cost the most time to
program, was the front end,
the stuff that you saw.
And we do that in AppEngine.
[CHIRPING]
My egg is now hard boiled.
So we do that in AppEngine.
All the stuff on the
bottom is basically
completely serverless.
So you take your video, you
upload it to Cloud Storage.
We have serverless functions
that are listening.
And if there's more
events happening,
we will spin up
automatically more functions
and then with each video we
pick up, we will call the API,
process it, extract
the metadata.
We take a metadata, so like,
the labels that you saw earlier,
which Lee demonstrated.
We see which index it happens.
And we will serve that up, in
this case with putting it back
on Cloud Storage.
But we could put
that in a database
or whatever else
we want to put it,
so we can make it searchable and
available for our application.
So if you think, if you've got
something around those APIs
that we just mentioned,
its like speech to text,
translation, processing
videos, processing images,
extracting sentiment from
images or recognizing where
people are standing on images.
There are many
things you can do.
And you can just use
a service architecture
and really get up to--
hit the ground running.
If you're going to
go deeper, and you're
going to start building
some of the stuff yourself,
there are a few things
I want to leave you with
to actually think
about in that process.
Make sure the
developers that are
working for you are
giving you good answers
on these questions.
So we want to do
machine learning.
We want to be here at the top
doing our machine learning.
We want to start getting
this predictive power
making a business impact.
It is right at the
top of this stack.
Right at the bottom
is infrastructure.
So again, using a
framework like TensorFlow
that you can run on
basically any architecture,
that gives you that capability.
If you're using
another project which
doesn't have those
capabilities, and then you
want to take something and
bring it into production,
you're going to have to have
your engineers find a way
to actually take that
from the research space
into the production space.
That is one of the key
motivators behind TensorFlow
inside Google itself.
The Google Brain team,
they were working,
they were doing research stuff.
And then when they tried
to move it to production,
basically there had to
be an engineering effort
to take those learnings
and that model,
and now how are we going to
get this thing in production?
So having infrastructure
that we can do that on,
and having the applications
that actually facilitate that,
is a very powerful thing.
As we move up, we
come to the kind of,
let's say the body
of water and the data
that we need to
actually run this on.
Some of the key challenges
there are around
collecting data,
processing data.
These are all major
efforts that need
to be made if you're actually
going to use machine learning.
So you have to have good
answers to these things.
And then on the top, we
can do machine learning.
If you don't do it like
this, you end up like this.
And this is basically
what'll happen.
You'll be up there
and you'll be like,
oh, I've got something
in production.
And bomb, it's gone, and
you've got a big problem.
This architecture,
and I won't go
into too many details
about this at the moment,
but I will just say that
this is an architecture we
use to help customers
build things
when they're using TensorFlow.
And the important
part to look at here
is that we have
frameworks like data flow
which is this one here, which
is actually unified batch--
a streaming framework.
What that means is,
I can take an action
I want to perform on my data,
like mapping, or a function
that I want to perform,
a processing action,
and I can apply
it to batch data.
So think about the
data that you already
have that you can use
to train your model.
But I can also apply it to
real time data, data coming in
on a stream.
The same model, just
making a few changes
of how the data's
actually coming in.
That's what a unified
model allows you to do.
So if you look at
the bottom there,
we have date flow coming.
So when you're ready to
make those predictions,
sometimes people forget.
I've just spent all this
time taking this data,
extracting all the features,
and then I trained a model.
Now we're going to
go make predictions.
What are you going to
make predictions on?
Yeah, I'm going to make
a prediction on this.
OK, so what do we have to do
with that to actually get it
in the same space
as our prediction?
Yeah, you have to
extract those features,
and now you see why
having a unified model
might actually make
a lot of sense.
They're both serverless as
well, and again, as I said,
they have open source projects.
Apache VM, which you can
create your stuff online.
You develop this crazy stuff.
All the things I said about
TensorFlow apply to Apache VM
as well--
developers working in
the community, something
which you can go and run
on different infrastructure
if you want to move,
that flexibility.
The other one is the Cloud ML.
So here we're using
it to train our data.
And here we are
using it to predict.
A question that
comes up quite often,
if I create something
in TensorFlow,
where am I going to
make my predictions?
Well, it's up to you.
You could take your
TensorFlow model
and deploy a compiled
version to your mobile phone.
So you could, for example,
you would be doing Translate
and like, I've seen the example
where we actually take--
you take your camera,
and you hold it up
against a sign, for
example, in Japanese,
and then it gives
you the English text.
But let's say you're not
online at the moment.
You still want that
functionality to work.
So you might be saying
in your application,
if I don't have an
internet connection, use
this local model, which
is going to be smaller.
It's going to be less powerful.
If I do have a connection,
then use this model.
And then you would
make an API call,
and then you can come back
to Cloud Machine Learning.
So you have that ability.
TensorFlow, itself, I'm letting
here into some of the things
I explain to developers
as well, because I
think this is where things
kind of go wrong if you're not
asking these questions.
So I just told you about all
the good thing about TensorFlow.
This is the engine
of TensorFlow.
If you want improve
the engine, you
have people work together
to actually collaborate
in that space.
But there's a lot going
on there at the moment.
It's pretty solid.
As you go up the
stack, these are
the kind of important things
to pay attention to, layers.
If you're building
models there, it's
a great place to learn
about machine learning.
But it's a place
that, when you want
to move from one
architecture to another,
you need to go and think about
how is that going to look?
How's that process
going to go run?
That's why we created estimators
and canned estimators.
An estimator itself gives you
the ability to actually just
say, this is my model.
This is something to think
about, doing all the wiring up.
And we have a custom
estimator as well.
So you can take advantage
of something very specific
that you want to create.
And you can take
that model and then
run it on your local machine.
But then also say, to
Cloud ML for example,
go and run this in a cloud
and train it on big data.
So it's really important--
the thing to take home
is, really important
to challenge
people, at what level are they
interacting with this stack?
Where are we?
Where should we be?
And right at the top there
are the canned estimators.
And these things these very,
these are out of the box.
They're not like the
machine learning APIs
that I showed you.
You still have to actually tell
how your data is going to fit,
and you have to
extract the features
and do more of
that kind of stuff.
But basically, if you've
got a common problem,
like a common
regression problem,
something like that,
there are estimators there
that you can use as well.
And this stuff, Keras.
Keras is other framework
which you can use,
which we support as well.
A lot of data scientists
are using Keras as well.
It also gives you
flexibility of back ends.
So there are things
to think about there.
And there are
things that to have
that discussion with your lead
data scientist, or the product
manager, or your
data science team,
and say, how we are
actually going to do this?
Or your data engineering
team-- and just
start asking some
of these questions.
It's not about necessarily
actually understanding what's
going on in all those layers.
But its having
good answers like,
are you going to build a model?
OK, can we train that
in different spaces?
What's the effort
that you need to make
to help me get this to
production, because I want this
in production because I
want to actually start
offering new capabilities
to my customers.
This, if you get
any time left today,
which I'm imagining you won't,
but if you do have any time,
downstairs is an
instant Insights demo.
And basically they show Cloud ML
making predictions about which
advert to show which taxi.
So imagine taxis
driving around town.
Some are coming from the
airport going into town.
Other ones are going back.
Some have three people
and some have two.
And this is a running
model you can go and look
at and basically
see the whole flow.
So we take the message.
And once we've received that
message, we make a prediction
and we say, oh, look, there's
one person in the taxi.
They're heading to the airport.
Maybe they'd like
to have a coffee.
Or there are three
people going into town.
Maybe they'd like to go
to this theater show.
You can draw your own
conclusions what's a good idea.
But the thing is, this
is all serverless.
So you can actually go and
see how you would set up
this production pipeline.
And the other thing
is here as well
to see is that we can take data
flow, and the same data that's
coming in to make our
predictions, we can filter
off and have it go
into our, for example,
bit query, which is
our data warehouse,
streaming real time with the
data that' already there.
So when someone phones up
and says there's a problem,
you can actually look at the
data you've been receiving
and query not only the data you
had yesterday, but the stuff
that's coming in now.
These kind of
capabilities enable
you to act in this space.
They enable you to
make things quickly.
get it to production.
And they enable you
to actually start
working with it in production
when you have problems.
That's the story that we
have around machine learning.
This is a photo of a TPU.
And I've got six minutes.
If there are any questions,
I'm happy to take some.
Silence.
Come n, someone
give me a question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
[INAUDIBLE] natural language.
But how come you
mentioned that [INAUDIBLE]
single, from a particular
project [INAUDIBLE],,
whether you have
equations or [INAUDIBLE]..
For example, you
have [INAUDIBLE]??
ROBERT SAXBY: So I would
say there's a few answers.
So the question is--
AUDIENCE: Repeat the question.
ROBERT SAXBY: Yeah, I'm
going I'm going to repeat it.
Yeah, I got that.
So the question is, when
natural language processing,
how do we cope with
different stacks?
Which one should we use?
Is one open, the
other one closed?
How do we navigate that space?
So the open APIs that
we have, those APIs
will give you capability
out of the box.
And so if I was
designing an application
and I wanted, for
example, my application
is, let's say I'm taking--
we used an example
earlier with that chat.
So the chat's coming in and
I want to process a chat
and actually have
a signal real time,
about saying if the person
is happy or angry so I can,
after the chat's finished, I can
maybe steer that chat somewhere
else to actually have
someone call back
or look into what
was going wrong,
and give a very
short turnaround.
If I was looking at
bringing those capabilities
to an application,
let's say soon,
quickly, I would
look at those APIs
and see if that fits, because
that's something you can really
speed up your development.
The good thing there, and if
you're going in that space
is, choose an API which is on
a good standard, a good rest
standard.
And you can actually, it's
a little work to implement.
And you can actually,
let's say, proxy,
so you can put
something in front of it
and actually work with it.
And if you want
to change that out
for some other capability
or some other vendor later,
the engineering
effort is very small.
If you're going to go,
let's say more specific,
and you're really trying
to target nuances which
are very unique to use case,
use something like TensorFlow
as opposed to, let's say,
one of our competitor's
offerings, which is
a little bit more
closed, because TensorFlow
is an open project.
If you get into problems,
it's not about one company
saying this is our thing.
It's something supported
by a whole group of people.
And they will give you
help in that space.
They will give you a chance to
take the development further.
And importantly, a question
I got asked recently
and I think it's really
worth thinking about as well,
was at some point
some organizations are
going to get asked a question.
And that question is going to
be, to an auditor, explain me
how it works.
And that is going to
be an exciting time.
So if you get that
question, it's
going to be really good to have
a system that you're using,
which is open and you can
use tools to actually look
at what's going in at
each level to provide data
to the auditor saying look,
you might not understand it,
but at least I can
show what's going on.
This is happening there.
It's not just some black
box and your core business
is now tied into this thing
that you can just say,
well, I ask it something
and it gives me an answer.
There's a big dialogue
around TensorFlow.
And even the models that
we use internally, we
have a lot of effort spent.
For example, for an
inception model for images
is a trained model in images
which we've brought out
into community so other people
can develop their own image.
So there's a lot of shared
knowledge in this space.
So I'd really tried
to be in that space
with the shared knowledge, so
you can have access to people
but also get access to what's
going on when you need to.
Does that answer your question?
OK, thank you.
SPEAKER 2: If there are other
questions, we have a mic now.
So everybody going
to need a question.
This is your chance.
ROBERT SAXBY: There's time
for one last question,
if there's a pressing question.
SPEAKER 2: Time for
one last question.
ROBERT SAXBY: Brave.
AUDIENCE: One of the issues
with speech recognition,
and living in the Netherlands
is that Dutch is mostly
one of the last
languages you support.
What is the speed you think
that something like that
will come here?
ROBERT SAXBY: So you're talking
like actually processing speech
to text?
So I'm not going to commit to
any like planning on stage.
I do know from my own
personal engagements
with company or personal,
like in a business context,
that we're really open to
have that conversation,
because if it's something
that's going to change what
you do, and you've
got a stake in it,
we're happy to be a partner to
explore those possibilities.
So we're happy to have
that conversation.
We are obviously working to have
that support for all languages.
It's just a question of
engineering, resources,
and linguists and
everything else
that we need to
make that happen.
So I lot of our models
have moved into NLP space
at the moment.
So you'll see a lot much better.
But if you have a specific
requirement around that,
maybe reach out to the field
sales that's on your table
if you have someone there.
Otherwise I will point
someone in your direction,
and let's have
that conversation.
That's something we're
really happy to talk about.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
Thank you Robert.
Robert will stick around, too.
So in the natural way the
agenda changed a little bit.
And at this point, we will
be at our round tables,
and your table lead will
lead the discussion.
And we take it from there, OK?
MARIO: My name is
Mario, and I'm going
to be your host for
the next 45 minutes
because I love the interaction
you're currently having
on the roundtable.
And we're going to go
a little bit deeper.
We're going to make
from the conversation,
we're going to turn
it into a challenge.
So I hope you're excited.
Yeah, a little bit?
OK.
So why are we doing this?
We are going to apply a
little bit of design thinking.
This is something that's very
deeply embedded in Google,
and we want to share
with you how that works.
But before I got to explain
what we're actually going to do,
I want to recap a little bit
and give you some context.
So digital is
radically redefining
how consumers interact and our
businesses are being shaped,
or need to transform.
If you think back the early
2000s, it was through the web.
Now it's through this device.
And in the very
near future, it's
going to be in much
more ambient ways
if you think of all the
intelligent devices that
are around you, and can
help you in any context.
So for example, Gardner
forecast that in just two years
time, one fifth of
the world's population
will have a virtual personal
assistant that they will
use in their mobile device.
And at Google, we
see the same sort
of transformation going on.
More than 50% of all the
queries happen on this device.
But what really strikes me
is that 20% of these queries
are voice based.
And that leads me to
the following thought.
This is a new area of
consumer experience.
It creates a new standard.
So think of it as,
you're not only
competing against
other companies,
but you're actually
competing against the best
experience a consumer has ever
had, regardless of industry.
So at Google, we
have the mission
to organize the
world's information
and make it relevant and
universally accessible.
And we do that in
many ways and shapes.
So what we're
going to do next is
to give you a closer look how
we are using that in the Google
Home, on your mobile
device, and even in the car.
And more importantly,
how you as a business
can also benefit from that.
So with that I'd like to
introduce my colleague, Lee.
Give her a big
round of applause.
And after that I'll
come back to you
to explain a little bit
more about the challenge.
LEE VONSTRA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Lee Vonstra.
I work as a customer
engineer for Google,
for Google Cloud Team.
And I'm here today
to talk a little bit
about Google Home
and Google Assistant,
just how that works
all under the hood--
also chatbots.
This picture that you see
here is actually a picture
that was made in 2016 of
what's on the Google I/O.
This is our CEO, Sundar.
And he came on stage and he
said like, at this time from now
on, we will move from a mobile
first world to a more AI
first world.
Now what does he mean?
Back in the past when we
were creating applications,
we made it that way,
that we'll make sure
that it works on a mobile
phone, because if it works
on a mobile phone then
we can use resize it,
do responsive design
and so that it
runs across any type of device.
And for a very long time,
that was our way of thinking,
our design thinking how we
would create applications.
But now we are on a time that
we collected so much data
and we have so much
computing power in the cloud
that we finally can
change our way of thinking
and make a more AI
first approach, where
we let our applications
or interfaces be
created by machine learning.
And we do that with
the Google Assistant.
And the Google Assistant,
that is our smart assistant,
is implemented in
all the latest Google
products that you can buy, like
think about the Google Watch,
think about the Android phone.
Think all Android phones
from the Marshmallow on up.
The Google Home, the smart
speaker, but also in cars
we're try to implement
there so that you can,
when you're driving
in a car, you
can ask like, oh, how
is my commute to Paris?
How should I drive?
Can you turn on
the radio, instead
of looking through a screen
or interacting with a screen.
So it's a conversation
between you
and Google that helps you to get
more things done in this world.
Now just to make a
couple of things clear,
the Google Home, that is the
voice activated speaker and it
really is nothing more
than a speaker that's
connected to the internet.
As a microphone,
you can talk to it,
but the whole magic around
it, that is actually
to Google Assistant.
So that is the conversation
between Google and you,
and that is implemented
in the phones,
but also in the Google Home.
Now you will also
hear me a couple times
referring to actions on Google.
What is that?
Think about it as apps.
It's how you can
extend the system.
So you can create your own
conversations, your own chat
logics, and implement that on
top of the Google Assistant.
And we can do that
with tools like API.AI,
which I will talk about later.
But just to let you know
what Google Assistant can do,
you can ask the Google
Assistant to manage tasks.
This photo that you
see here is actually
a question to the
assistant, like, yeah,
what's my confirmation number
to my flight to Philadelphia?
And then the Google Assistant
will answer you with the PNR
that they got from the flight.
How does the
assistant know that?
Well, you're locked into
a Google account, which
has connection to your
email and all that,
and your calendar and so on.
So the Google Assistant
is smart enough
to figure that out for you.
You can ask things like, OK,
how will how will my transit be?
Is it busy on the road?
And the Google
Assistant will know that
by connecting to all kinds
of external services.
So you can use it
to plan the day.
But you can also use
it to ask questions.
So I could, for
example, ask like,
who's the King of
the Netherlands?
And the assistant will answer,
well, that's Willem-Alexander.
But then my next question
could be like, OK,
and what's the name of his wife?
And then, the
Assistant will know
that the context is
Willem-Alexander, so his wife,
her name is Maxima.
So I mean that is something
that is very smart.
You need more than a decision
tree to figure that out.
You need to understand
the context.
what was passed in
and to keep that context.
You can use also the
Assistant for making memory,
so I can ask, like, what is my
favorite-- my favorite color is
blue.
And if I ask the Google
Assistant next week, what
is my favorite color again?
Then the Assistant will know,
well, you told me it was blue.
So it can remember things.
And you can also use it
to control your home,
if you have all types of smart
devices like the Philips hue
bulbs or the Nest.
You can say, oh,
turn on the lights.
Turn up the heat.
Turn the volume on, or
play my favorite TV show
from YouTube or on Netflix.
As long as you have
smart devices that
are connected to
the internet, then
your Google Assistant can
communicate with that.
Here, I came up
with an example how
you can implement that logic for
Google Home, or for the Google
Assistant, within your company.
I mean, we're working
with companies,
and I assume that we all have
internal applications running.
Those are applications that
are run behind a firewall.
So one of such applications
could be a meeting room
application, to
book a meeting room.
So I could, for example,
ask the Assistant hey,
OK, Google, let me talk
the book a meeting room.
Book a meeting room in this
case is my custom action.
It is the action that I, as
a developer, will create.
And what you will see
is, the Google Assistant
will talk back.
And it will say like, OK, sure
here is book a meeting room.
And then, at that moment,
the voice of the assistants
will change, because then
it will go to a voice
that the developer chose
for their custom action.
So you're coming into the
custom action flow now.
So think about it
as an app or a flow.
And it will start asking
with the welcome in text,
like, OK, welcome.
How can I help you?
And I say like, OK, yeah,
I'd like to book a meeting
room for three persons.
Sure, for when?
Tomorrow from 2:00 to 3:00 PM.
And what happens here is,
tomorrow from 2:00 to 3:00 PM--
or I want to book a meeting
room for three persons.
Three persons is a
parameter that will
be sent to an external system.
So imagine that you have
a book a meeting room
internal application,
which has a REST API.
I just pass in three
persons, and then the API
would handle it back.
It would say, OK, the
next request that I should
make is a request for the time.
OK, tomorrow from
2:00 to 3:00 PM.
And then the system will tell
me back like, OK, it went fine.
The meeting room is booked.
And then the Assistant
can tell me that.
Or, the meeting room was
not booked because maybe it
was already booked before.
And then it can come up
with a second suggestion.
Something like this is
not so difficult to create
with a tool like API.AI.
API.AI is like a
developer console.
It's like a SaaS application,
a website you call there.
And you can create
all these intents,
so you can write out
these conversations.
But it also contains
machine learning
so you can train the system.
So when you ask questions,
it becomes smarter over time.
If you ask the question
a little bit wrong,
it will understand
which question
you meant because it got trained
through machine learning.
So API.AI is a developer console
that you can start using.
And when you use that, you
create your conversation
only once.
And then you can implement
it for various solutions.
So I can deploy
it on Google Home.
I can deploy it on
Facebook as a bot,
and then I need to add
that person, the bot,
as a friend in my
Facebook account
and I can start talking to it.
I can have a chatbot
on my website.
I can implement it
easily with an I-frame,
or I can integrate it real in
my own system and in my own look
and feel for phones.
You name it, we have
all the integrations
already available in
API.AI developer console.
It's just a matter
of flipping a switch.
Actions SDK, that is a
client library that's
currently written in note.
That is in-case API.AI
is limited for you,
or in case you want to extend
and do some more magic,
then you can choose to implement
all these ideas by yourself.
It is a little bit more work,
because then you also need
to come up with natural
language processing and machine
learning, which API.AI
has out of the box.
So here you can see
it again, that can you
book a meeting room for
tomorrow from 2:00 to 3:00 PM.
I call that service
Book A Meeting Room,
and I pass in tomorrow,
2:00 to 3:00 PM.
The web intent, this is API.AI,
you create a web intent there.
And you can see that
as a kind of flow,
it's a mapping between
what the user says
and the action that
needs to be taken.
So for example, I created
a while ago a Google Home
application where I could
ask to Google Home, hey,
what's on TV tonight?
Oh, on what channel?
I want to know what's
on TV on RTL 4.
And then it would read out
a whole programming type.
How would I do that?
I would create a
web intent where
I ask, what's on a channel?
And then the user can pass in
whatever channel they like.
But it will take that
whatever, this part,
it will be fired
to the background.
And I assume that I
have some kind of magic,
or some kind of service there,
that can query the TV Guide.
But the thing that I passed
in, that is an entity.
So you can pre-define
a bunch of entities.
See it as parameters.
So you know that there is
some kind of hard variable
that you need to send to the
system so that you can act on.
So this is what you see here.
Here, you create
the web intents.
They are the entities.
There is a section
for integrations.
This is for changing if you
want and deploy it on Facebook,
or on Slack, or on Skype.
And there's also a section
for training the APIs.
So if you have created
these web intents
and people have been asking
questions, you can train it.
You can correct it if it
gave you the wrong answer.
You can say, OK, well, next
time don't answer this anymore,
and then it will remember that.
Here you see the
webhook in parameters.
There So you can
create webhooks.
This is actually,
you enable a webhook
and then you pass in the URL to
your external web applications.
And then when you
create your intent,
you just click on Actions
and you say like, OK,
every time when
I ask this event,
or this intent,
actually you need
to act on through a webhook.
And then I give it a
webhook name, in this case,
Get By Channel, that will
be passed to that URL.
Now what I did in the
background for this is I
used Cloud Functions.
But you can use any type
of background you like.
The reason why I choose
Google Cloud Functions
is because, in
this case, I don't
need to worry about the
virtual machine or server.
I just create a function
somewhere in the cloud
and then let Google scale
all the machines for me,
and I just don't care
about backgrounds at all.
So I just create a
JavaScript function
in this case that would
query the TV Guide.
I don't think we need
to go into this now.
This is very technical.
But ask me if you have
questions about it.
Just so you know, these
kind of Cloud Functions,
you can write that
on the Google Cloud
in a native editor on
the Cloud platform.
So you don't need to
install any tools.
You can just do it right away.
Yes, and then you
deploy your action.
And once you deploy your
action, then you can test it.
So this is within the
Google Cloud Platform,
there is a web simulator.
And there you can authorize
it with your Google account,
and then you say like,
this is my API.AI account
that I'm currently using.
And at that moment,
in the simulator
you get like a similar
behavior as if you
would have a real Google Home.
So I could start typing to it
and it gives me answers back.
But I could also use the
microphone for my computer
and ask questions.
And then it would
read out the answers
as if it would be
the Google Assistant.
Once you're done,
when you're really
happy with this conversation,
then you can deploy it.
And kind of like an app store,
you need to register the name
and then it will be whitelisted
in the Google App Store,
or in Assistant
App Store, kind of.
That means that there's
approval process.
Somebody within Google
will check your bot,
see if it's valid enough.
See also if you don't let
the microphone open nonstop,
because that is actually
one of the guidelines.
You can never leave
the microphone open.
Out of the box that doesn't
work on a Google Home.
It always keeps it open
for a minute or maybe less,
and then automatically
shuts off.
But if you don't
let your users know
that the microphone is open,
then your [INAUDIBLE] process
will fail.
So make sure that you always
ask for more questions.
So when you create
a conversation,
you should always answer
like, OK, this is the answer.
Do you like to hear more?
OK, and this is the answer.
And in case you're really
interested in this,
in creating Google Assistant
conversations, or using API.AI,
there is this design
document that Google
created that can help you
with creating conversations
like this.
Definitely a good read.
I think with that I can
hand it over to you, Mario.
MARIO: Thanks, Lee!
LEE VONSTRA: Yes.
MARIO: Well, thank you, Lee.
What we try to do is
to basically show you
the technical toolkit.
So the next ingredient we
want to share with you,
and after that you're really
going to get your hands dirty,
is a conceptual
creative toolkit.
So if you can switch to
the next slide, thank you.
So this is all about
creating the future.
You now have the
opportunity together
to create a future together.
If you go to next slide.
So at Google, we think of
creativity and innovation
not as an event.
We see it as a process,
perhaps even more as a mindset.
And we worked a
couple of years ago
to get with Stanford's IDEO
and a couple of other experts
to develop this method, which
is called designed thinking.
And basically, it consists
of three main concepts.
So I wanted to walk you
through, because I think it's
very useful in your exercise.
So the first one is,
if you are starting
to build something you don't
start with a revenue model
and buying some
great technology.
It always starts with
knowing the user.
Once you know the user,
their beliefs, their needs,
that's the perfect
starting point
to build a magical solution.
Now the next part
you want to do--
and basically, again
some practical guides.
You could apply a
framework of three pillars
of knowing the user.
The first is analyze.
So what data do you have
available to analyze the user?
Second one is observe.
There are ways you can
observe your users.
And the third one
is to ask them.
There's no better inputs than
asking a user how they feel,
what they need, et cetera.
So the second one, Andrea
Cabus already touched upon.
We don't think in incremental
improvements of 10%,
but we want to improve
and think about 10x.
A perfect Google example,
I think, is Google Loon.
In rural areas where
there was no Wi-Fi,
it was a childish idea to
come up with air balloons that
could send out Wi-Fi signals.
But it's these ideas that
in a grown up setting
are considered impossible,
which are the strongest ideas.
So ask yourself in
the team, what if,
because asking the what if
question will make it bigger.
And a final one is
be proto driven.
You want to make sure
that you fail fast,
because if you
incorporate that, you
will learn if you succeed,
but also if you fail you
can incorporate that learning.
So we see the success not by
how high your success rate is,
but how often you
have tried something.
OK, go to the next one.
All right, so coming back, Lee
gave you the technical toolkit,
how you can build a
conversational customer
experience.
I hope I've just gave you
a little bit of a toolkit
how you can have a creative
process to come up.
So we're going to
put that together.
So the challenge,
we ask you, and you
can continue the conversation
you had in your roundtable,
redesign the customer experience
by creating a concept that
uses this conversational AI.
So that's your objective.
We're going to have
hand out tables
on the round tables,
which is a framework you
can use to put in your ideas.
You're going to be time limited.
I'm sorry, we're
already far over time.
But again, you only
have 20 minutes.
Your chance to
win a Google Home,
I'm afraid I can't keep
up with that promise.
We don't have Google
Homes, unfortunately.
But the important thing is--
it was not intended
to be in there.
So apology.
It's going to be
Netherlands, end of year.
We're going to score
based on business impact.
So how big is the
impact you're going
to come up with the concept?
What's the customer
experience like?
So who is your customer?
What are the integrations
you could use?
So that could be your own
data, could be external data.
And finally,
originality-- could you
make a flow describing
the conversation
you would be having
with a customer,
with one of your partners,
employees, et cetera?
OK, go to the next slide.
So as a final example, to give
you some food for thought,
this is a very cool concept that
eBay demoed a couple of weeks
ago.
So I bought a camera
six years ago,
but with the technological
advancement of smartphones
I think the camera in my pocket
is far more powerful and easy
to use.
So I don't use my
bit camera anymore.
So what I actually
could ask Ebay is,
how much is my camera worth?
And it would ask me
a couple of questions
like, OK, tell me the brand,
the color, the condition.
And it would then search
in its own great database
and could provide me with
a very precise estimation
of how much my camera is worth.
I think these are
the kinds of concepts
you might be thinking about.
So with that, I wish
you all good luck.
And the 20 minutes starts now.
AUDIENCE: Here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIO: That's the
end of the challenge,
so please finish
your discussions.
It's a good sign, I think.
You're having great
conversations.
So at the end of the
challenge, what we'd like to do
is to have a couple of teams
come onstage to share with us
their great concepts
they came up.
So are there any
volunteers that think,
my concept is the
next big thing.
Awesome.
What's your name, sir?
EDWIN: Edwin.
MARIO: Edwin?
EDWIN: Yeah.
MARIO: Hi, Edwin.
Can I ask you to pitch your
concept you and your team
came up?
EDWIN: I will.
All right, so the idea started
from the company I work for.
Part of the activity is a
retail store around gardening,
pets, and baking.
And what we wanted
to do is to create
Rop, the personal gardening
coach, because what we are,
we are a retail store, or retail
chain, that provides premium
products with a
premium of advice,
and by doing so justify
a premium price.
But of course, if we have to
wait until the customer shows
up in our store with a problem
that we can help to solve,
then we might miss
an opportunity.
So the idea would be that we
create a personal gardening
coach, which is a
chatbot in an app,
so that when a client of
ours walks through the garden
and spots a bug on
some of the plants,
that he can open the app,
call up Rop, and say hi,
I've got a problem.
I've spotted a bug.
And then the chatbot would say,
OK, let's see what we can do.
Can you send me a picture?
Which would mean
access to the camera.
You send a picture and then you
start an entire conversation.
And at the end of
the conversation,
you would have a
solution to the problem.
It would have the
link to a product
and it would be able to
tie it to an online order
or a reference to
the nearest store
to come and pick up the product
that we might provide to them.
And then it became really spacey
because we said, you know,
we have added value services.
What would you think if we'd
send over a drone right now
to do a scan of your garden
as an added value service,
so that we can find out how
your garden is organized?
And what if this bug we
spotted might spread out
to other areas in your garden?
That was one of the
fancier ideas around it.
So what is the business impact?
Well, the business
impact is that we
are there for our clients the
moment they spot something.
So the moment they
detect something
that we can assist them
and find a solution.
We can tie back to
a full experience.
So it's an online order or a
reference to a nearest store.
And we would get better
insight, because if we
spot a bug in a
certain area, and we
know that that is something
that spreads very easily,
we would be able, based
upon client information,
to send out warnings to
other clients saying, well,
there is something going
on in the neighborhood.
Be aware, and if something
goes wrong with the plans,
there's a very big
likelihood that it
might be linked to this.
In terms of integrations, well,
voice API, image and video API,
geolocation--
where are you?
Dear Mr. Client, but
based upon what you
have on the phone that's easy.
Then of course, the client
profile data we have.
Geolocation, weather data API--
maybe there is something
wrong in that area because
of lack of water or
something, a lack of rain
like we are
experiencing right now.
And then of course, a
bug disease and solution
database that we need
to tie it all together.
So you see a lot of
integration points.
And we're not even
talking about the drone.
So in the customer flow, that's
what I already explained.
So the customer journey,
you walk through the garden.
You see something and
you open the chatbot,
and you start having
the conversation.
MARIO: I loved idea one.
One question.
Would you also have
a female assistant?
EDWIN: Of course.
MARIO: Great.
I love the idea.
Any other volunteers?
Come up front.
What's your name, sir?
HEIT: Heit.
MARIO: Heit.
HEIT: Heit OK.
MARIO: Excellent.
HEIT: Thank you.
Hello, my name is Heit.
And we're in the home
care business, I think,
or supporting the home care
system in the Netherlands.
[INAUDIBLE] the Netherlands.
So we looked at another
solution for home care nurses.
So the nurse assistant would
be a male, I think, probably.
I think they're really
independent nurses.
They're most of the time
at home with patients,
so assistant would be
appropriate I think.
Most of the time they
need to supply themselves
with materials for
wounds, for other things
for the patient at home.
So what are things
they will need
external people to help them?
That's one thing we
do with our company,
to just help them
with IT solutions,
to provide them information.
But I think the
customer experience
could be for supplying
them with medical supplies
without any extra time for
calling to other companies
for delivering them.
So the business impact would be,
they will have much more time
with the patients.
That's something we
always want to try
to do with our solutions.
So let me read something.
That's most important
business impact,
I think, that it will have more
time with the patients and less
time administrating things.
So the assistant
will start, I think,
with personal health records.
Social media ratings could be
an integration for looking up
ratings for suppliers.
Speech API, of course.
Electronic health
records we already have.
And maybe personal
data from patients
when they are at home, when do
you want something delivered?
Well, how could it work?
So the assistant would
ask, what do you need?
Well, I know it's Mr. X,
because I'm already there.
So the system knows.
He has a wound.
OK, well, what do you want
to do, based on the wound?
Well, I want some new supplies.
So it could be a question
you can ask to the assistant.
Well, in connection with
the data that we already
have, or could be available,
then you could say,
well, is there already a wound--
are the materials ordered?
Can we ask you when
you are at home?
At what time should
it be delivered?
So it could be in
combination type outs
based on some questions.
And eventually they
will order the supplies.
And I think the benefit would
be that the supplier would
do the rest.
So the nurse can go
to the next patient.
So that's part of our
brainstorm session solution.
MARIO: Thank you, Heit.
So no more visits to the doctor.
We have room for
one final concept.
Yeah?
One more.
You want to go as well?
OK, we're going to have two.
Ladies first.
But you need to be a little bit
shorter on time to make sure
that we cover both.
Thanks.
What's your name?
DIVIA: Divia.
MARIO: Divia.
DIVIA: Yes.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Divia.
And the product,
or the innovation
that we are launching
is called as Companion.
So it's a companion
for the elderly people.
And we see that there are lots
of issues in our society now
because all of us are
becoming very individualistic.
There's a lot of growth
in the elderly age group,
and they have lots
of aging effects--
going into depression,
feeling loneliness,
and lots of old age illness.
So what does the business
impact to our Companion
would be that we will
increase the quality of life
for the elderly.
We will bring happiness
to their life.
And we will improve
their healthy life state,
which in turn would
help us in society
and lower the health cost
and the insurance cost.
And I'll go to the customer
flow first, and then
the integration.
So it's morning.
The Google Home
talks, hello, Richard.
So the interaction is
starting from the Google Home.
So it's not like, I have
to speak to my Google Home.
It's Google Home speaking to me.
And through Natural
Language Processing, NLPs,
we can identify the
mood of the person.
We can identify time of the day.
We can identify the
agenda of the person.
Looking at the weather,
health of the person,
we can have a call to action
in terms of each one of that.
To give you an example, if I
haven't spoken since morning,
it will call to action
to my friends or family
that there's something wrong.
I'm not in a right mood, or
I'm not having good health,
so it will call my relatives.
If the weather is nice,
it will call my friends
to play bridge with me.
If it's raining outside and
if I have to go outside,
it will advice me to
carry my umbrella.
So this is the customer flow
just to give you an example.
And the integrations, third
box was integrations to APIs.
It could be with
voice recognition,
to interpret my mood.
It could be with the health
care systems, the weather data,
the sentiment analysis,
insurance companies,
medical records,
and the pill box.
Thank you.
MARIO: Wow.
Really amazing.
The last team that can
present with a plant.
Oh my god.
Is this your Google Home?
What's your name, sir?
PETER: Peter.
MARIO: Hello, Peter.
PETER: Hi.
MARIO: One minute.
PETER: OK, you want to be short?
You asked me to be shorter.
OK.
Actually, this is Wilson.
You know Wilson from
the movie "Outcast?"
Actually, the first, the
lady, ladies first, her idea
is brilliant.
Actually, we had the same idea.
But we already have
the solution here.
This is the interface
for the elderly.
You can speak to your plant.
It sees you, it feels you.
So this is the solution.
And we just build on the
APIs that they were making.
So, you know, here's
the partnership.
MARIO: And actually
to first team,
how to make sure the
plant doesn't die, right?
PETER: [INAUDIBLE]
MARIO: OK, cool.
Excellent.
So I'd like to close off.
I hope you've had fun, great
interaction with your table,
learned from new
people some new ideas.
And I really hope
that you can take away
to start tomorrow building
the new future using some
of the conversational toolkit.
So with that, I'd
like to close off.
Please give another round
of applause for yourself.
And I'd like to invite Eric
Haddad for the closing session.
It's OK?
ERIC HADDAD: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, OK.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
So I understand I
am the last speaker,
so I will try to be very short.
So I want just to give you--
to not let you leave without
having to say you shot a bit.
We stated of the business
that we have hopefully now
with Google Cloud.
So I'm running the business
for Google Cloud in Europe,
so I'm looking at [INAUDIBLE]
like countries in Europe.
So [INAUDIBLE] or Holland
and Belgium and Luxembourg.
And so you know, I joined
Google enterprise--
actually it wasn't Google
Enterprise six years ago.
And I used to work at Microsoft
before so I am in this cloud
business for, I've been
in this cloud business
for the last 10 years.
What I can see, and what I
can say, is at the beginning,
the description was coming
from Google to Microsoft,
actually, with the [INAUDIBLE]
platform and mobility.
It was the kind of description
we could see at the beginning.
So, was very beginning.
So we saw kind of linear
growth, on the cloud adoption,
depending on the country.
But we could say that
Nordic countries were maybe
a little bit early adopter--
France as well, UK as well.
And now we start to see
quite a big acceleration.
This description comes
from machine learning
and data management is
where I see the description.
And it is where I see, when
I discuss with customers
like you, from all
industries across Europe,
what we see is a lot of
discussion related to machine
learning, data management.
Why?
Because there was a big
impact with a business.
There is a big drive
already to a business.
And CIO, CDO, and so on, they
look for this kind of impact
and they can look at
very direct correlation.
So we see this exertion.
And what we do as well in
order to do all this exertion
is to invest.
So we have-- we probably
learn about that.
We have approx.
500 new releases of
services, I think
that for the last 12 months.
And we continue to have
quite an ambitious road map.
We are missing $28
billion dollars of capex
in terms of data centers
and infrastructure.
So over the next few years, so
the big, big, big investment
from Google in order to be
very present, very serious,
in this cloud business.
And we are looking
for more investments.
So we want to be a real
partner for enterprise,
not only for start up.
Start up and dot com
companies I think,
we're quite recognized for that.
We want to invest more
in order to be sure
that for enterprise
business, all industries,
we have this recognition
as a partner.
So we are investing
in your success.
And I mean that we are not
selling product, hopefully.
I mean, that's a kind
of mindset that I
want the team to have
with you is more,
we are trying to understand your
challenges, your priorities.
And in order to
make that, we have
to reorgnize our team in terms
of verticals, industries,
so we are trying to have people
with a mind set of vertigo,
like banking, like
manufacturing, like gaming.
And to be sure that we
understand, for sure,
from day zero we cannot
understand everything.
But at least people
in the team, we
try to learn from your
challenge and prioritizing that
to be sure they understand and
they can give you good answers.
And so, in order also to be
sure that you benefit from best
practices, we always are
trying also to integrate,
to share our best practices that
we have in terms of economics
in order to give you some
solution in terms of AI,
in terms of what works
and what does not work,
in terms of business solution.
And lastly in terms of
something very tangible,
we are, as we speak, we
are hiring 3,000 people,
technical people, from
pieces to posters.
It's quite big, I can tell you.
[INAUDIBLE] first time I see it
so bigger, having investment.
So in part of a
commitment of hiring.
So every week we have a dozen of
new candidates that we approve.
And hopefully are we are able
to bring these people in front
of you, for workshop but
also technical support
and any support or technical
advice that you need.
Today we have some [INAUDIBLE].
See, this is like old times.
So I should have removed it.
Actually, I'm sure you saw this
slide, so in a few [INAUDIBLE]..
So we have two million
customers-- enterprise
customers, B2B customers.
And what's new today,
quite with some modesty,
we are walking with
all industries.
You could say before, some
industries, some vertical
were a little bit scared
of us, with the cloud
and maybe with Google.
So today we work with big
bank like BBVA, BCG, ING.
So we have a real conversation
and real partnership,
strong partnership with bank.
We also have strong parnership
with a few [INAUDIBLE] as well.
And as you know, there is
a quite very important rule
called GDPR in Europe.
Good to come by May next year.
So we are planning to be
absolutely compliant for that.
We need to be absolutely
comfort with that.
We'll be compliant.
OK?
So I can tell you, it's not--
because I got some question
already to that.
Be relaxed.
It is all life, [CHUCKLES], OK?
If we are not GDPR compliant,
we stop the business, OK?
We be GDPR compliant.
So we have a plan for that.
We communicate.
Maybe we don't
communicate enough, OK?
And I would just [INAUDIBLE]
to see how we can better
communicate poor activity with
our customer to be sure, do you
understand the plan and roadmap.
And for sure, I need
to mention that we
have quite a huge business
with [INAUDIBLE] and fashion.
And so in all Europe,
most of the big brand--
not all, but many
of the big brand
in retail and fashion
and relative business,
we have quite a
good partnership.
There is no good customer
discussion without partners.
And we say the
partnering evolution
has been somewhere a
mirroring of the business, OK?
So when the business was still
immature, OK, like a niche,
the partners were mostly
niche partners, OK?
Very good partners
but niche partners.
And the more we evaluate
and we offer you,
we get to a level of maturity
of this business and the cloud
business, and the level of
conversations mature for you.
And the more we have
also other partners.
So we diversify partners.
We have also still niche
partners-- very specialized.
But we have also more and
more large [INAUDIBLE],,
like [INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE].
And also software as
a service partner kind
of application providers
that are also completing
the ecosystem of partnerships.
And to be very
clear, partnership
for us is quite
important, is [INAUDIBLE]..
We can have a direct
conversation with you.
But we have always partners
not between us but at least
with us, to be sure that we
have the best complete solution
for you and that the [INAUDIBLE]
and the success of the project
is guaranteed.
Talking about
partners-- I'm not going
to talk too much [INAUDIBLE].
But I wanted to take the
opportunity of this session
to give you an example of
three or four customer.
So, OK, very different.
The first one is obviously
the France in space.
That the leader in
satellite imagery, OK?
So the problem was to deliver
a high quality of image
when you have snow, OK?
You can imagine that.
Imagine when you have snow,
you obviously also cloud.
And when I say "cloud,"
not the IT cloud.
I mean the cloud--
real cloud in the sky.
And [INAUDIBLE]
it's quite difficult
to identify with what is
cloud and what is snow, OK?
And so what we did was
[INAUDIBLE] them to solve
a problem that was
they span several years
to improve the quality.
And a few months--
a couple of months--
I think, three months
maximum, we willfully
improve a lot the
quality of the image.
So that mean customer
satisfaction--
that's quality to machine
learning, customer
satisfaction, and
hopefully more business.
Ocado-- that the
pure grocery online.
The UK-- quite a good
[INAUDIBLE] in the UK.
Many today.
So they have no store.
You probably heard that to
some companies like Amazon.
But stores, OK?
And so this company
does not have store.
They are only online.
So for them, the key success
factor is customer services.
They need to have a fantastic
customer satisfaction
and be sure the answer to
any problem [INAUDIBLE]..
So in order to manage and to
do a triage of text or messages
or calls from the
customers, OK, they're
using the platform-- machinery
platform-- in order to triage.
And hopefully, they can
announce where there was a time
accompanying, they can
answer very quickly
and solve the issue--
so business as well.
Spotify-- you know probably
this leading companies
in music streaming.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
and the problem,
they want to be sure
that every one of us
is able to have all
the music you want
or we want in your hand.
So what we do is to
make possible to have
a maximum of
[INAUDIBLE] to the user
to be sure they are
happy with the music
hopefully they get from Spotify.
Air Liquide the last
example, Air Liquide
is quite a very old company,
probably the oldest one
company-- very traditional--
in France, part of the CAC 40.
They are [INAUDIBLE] company.
And they were in the process of
acquisition and growth as well.
So looking for new talent.
And they were not
able to acquire
so much because their
IT was quite obsolete
and not organized to
acquire new companies.
So what they did was
to start the process
of [INAUDIBLE] with BCG,
the Boston Consulting Group.
And from this first [INAUDIBLE],,
they went to the creation
of a night--
what they call a night
lab-- a kind of lab,
OK-- out of the company
to understand and to look
at the new processes and new
ideas of business and usage
they need to have for entering
the new world of digital.
They did it.
And from that, we enter an
additional transformation.
We help them to
manage transformation
of whole the users--
I mean, 50,000 users.
And now they just got
the acquisition of Airgas
in the US--
20,000 users.
And we're working with them
for the next transformation.
That the kind of
transformation we did.
So all coming up to you.
So and that somewhere what
we need to have is as a DNA,
when we are not [INAUDIBLE],,
is for to be sure that you are
accessed to when your customer
or prospect or partner--
you have access to all
innovation-- innovation
from Google by discussing
with product manager,
discussing with
all of people based
in Amsterdam or in
Europe, and also
to our partners or ecosystems.
So we are also looking always
for new partnership in order
to bring more value to you or in
terms of benefits for your user
or for your customers.
Looking at always on that
principle I love is having--
since I work for traditional
companies, I would say,
I love to see that we are
not looking contractually,
technically, commercially
the business with you.
So what we are trying to do is
to always be very open in terms
of platform, in terms
of conceptualization
and be sure that when you
hopefully you work with us,
and we have a partnership,
this partnership is not
something like one unique,
a mono partnership.
It has to be a
[INAUDIBLE] partnership.
We understand perfectly
well that you should have--
and maybe is that
an advice from me--
you should have a
multi-cloud strategy
in order to be sure that you
can hopefully manage abilities
for [INAUDIBLE] and
leverage what you need, OK?
And so lastly, so
something quite new
because when I look at the first
years I was working at Google,
I was worried that we didn't
have professional services.
So at the beginning, so we
are adding some support.
Now fully we have a professional
services organization,
that not a professional
services organization that
is for replacing the partners.
This is for completing
the partners
or just to be sure that
you feel secure, OK,
or you feel that your project
will go to success, OK?
And that just for that, OK?
The purpose of this professional
service is that we want to be
big enough to be good--
not good, great--
in terms of impact for you,
but not too big to not create
some uncomfortable
for the partners
ecosystem is part of the plan
fully of the new Google Cloud
that you want to have for you.
So my conclusion--
I think that the
first time in advance.
It's 1 minute, 20.
[CHUCKLES]
Only one thing I would
love that you keep
is if you are in the process of
integration with Google Cloud
today, one thing you should
just open for conversation,
for Discovery Workshop, OK?
Work with the team.
I'm sure you know most of the
people in the Amsterdam office
or the [INAUDIBLE] office.
Start a discussion for
Discovery Workshop,
and identify the project
where we could help you, OK?
Maybe problem that you
don't know how to solve.
Maybe we have a solution.
And that free.
OK, that absolutely free.
We can invest some
time with you in order
to be sure that you can get
some plan of [INAUDIBLE],, OK?
So no need for a big project.
We can start small discussion.
Look at what you
need short term.
And after, we learn by
walking through it all.
So I'm done with
my presentation.
I told you, it's short.
20 seconds left.
I understand that we
have also cocktail.
Andre probably
would present that.
So we'll have some
glass of wine--
hopefully good wine--
have good wine?
Not sure.
Yeah.
[CHUCKLES] Good wine.
So I'm happy to follow
up with you, OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIC HADDAD: Discussion--
happy to discuss with you.
Bye-bye.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDRE HOEKZEMA: Thank you, Eric.
And thank you, everybody.
And I hope the wine is good.
And this brings us to
the end of this day.
And I really hope you enjoyed
and got inspired today
with the keynotes, with
the machine learning,
with all the possibilities
that we brought.
I really hope that you
got inspired by imagining
the future like you did.
And I hope you got inspired
by exploring possibilities
with the design thinking and all
the things that we discussed.
I saw some great
examples of that.
And I don't want
to close, really.
Actually instead, I want to
do two proposals-- whoops.
[CHUCKLES] I want
to do two proposals.
One-- stay connected.
So all the folks here
on the tables, right?
So we have customer
engineers with Lee.
And we have here the
business people with Petra.
Every table has them.
We have our services
organization.
We have our partner
We have our marketing
organization.
And by the way, super thank
you for Susana and Shelby
for pulling this off.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I want to propose,
stay connected.
And start a project
in a safe environment
because we believe at Google to
just create a safe environment.
And experiment stuff.
Just start stuff.
Just do maybe some
stuff that's already
bubbled up at the tables here.
Let's continue.
Let's continue the discussion.
Now we are all connected.
And let's keep the conversation
going in a safe environment.
And it's OK to fail.
Don't worry.
And do it a few times.
You know how that works, right?
And at some point, the
future you imagined
might be closer, OK?
The second proposal
is-- and Eric already
gave a little bit a heads
up-- we have a boat, right?
And the boat is park--
you can get on the
boat from 5 o'clock.
So if you walk easy to
the boat, and there will
be Lollipop girls and boys.
And they will bring
us to the boat.
And we have an awesome
time till 7:00 on the boat.
We will have nice drinks.
And I hope the wine is good.
Really, Eric, I hope so.
[CHUCKLES]
So thank you again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]